in Captain America Civil War we're
looking at the repercussions of all of
the Marvel movies up to this point so
the war is about the government saying
hold on a second Avengers just because
you can be first responders across the
globe doesn't mean you should be all
superheroes should be registered there
should no longer be vigilantes cap
believes there's one course of action
that should take and Tony believe
there's another there's this rift and we
put their relationship in the balance as
well as the Avengers
we wanted to have a third party who
wasn't even necessarily involved in that
argument and we kept talking up like
pepper
he's a monarch and at the same time he's
this superhero but there's a certain
mystery about the character fun thing
about civil war is it's almost as many
players as we've ever had in our films
showing up together so Wanda Maximoff
for instance who we saw struggle with
her abilities in Ultron we see exactly
how powerful she is she's more
understanding of her skills and she has
like quite a great amount emotional
journey in this one it's not villain
versus hero it's it's friends it's
family Civil War is the right movie in
the right moment for where the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is and for where
these characters are it's gonna
challenge the way that you think about
Tony Stark it's going to challenge the
way that you think about Steve Rogers
and when you come out of that film
nothing will be the same
hey youtubers is Charlie so this video
is gonna be all about how civil war in
the comics got started and how they
might change that for the movie there's
also a bunch of secret war stuff that's
happening a whole bunch of Marvel stuff
happening in the last couple of weeks
let's start with the important stuff
first comic books Civil War two movies
Civil War you may or may not have read
comic books Civil War it was about ten
years ago in the comics what happened
quite a while ago they're taking a lot
of elements from that and using that for
Captain America Civil War but because of
a lot of the changes that the movies
have already made to the comics it's not
gonna help you a lot to read comic books
Civil War but it's still a really good
story it's still a lot of fun it's not
quite as crazy as Secret Wars was but
Secret Wars is a big multiverse spanning
events so yummy you get the idea the one
or two big things that linked comic
books Civil War to Captain America Civil
War or the sokovia accords in the movie
in the superhero Registration Act from
the comics as well as the fight between
Captain America and Iron Man in the
comics the superhero Registration Act is
something that the government comes up
with after a series of incidents you
know quote-unquote incidents with
superheroes it's meant to be a control
for what they call living weapons of
mass destruction most people when they
think about the beginning of civil war
in the comics they really just think
about the incident in Stamford
Connecticut but what happened is is the
New Warriors a team of really young
superheroes we're trying to take down
another group of young super villains
they chased them down to a random house
in Stamford Connecticut in the suburbs
near a school they got into a fight one
of the super villains nitro goes nuclear
causes this huge blast kills over 600
people including a bunch of children and
anybody else that was nearby so in the
eyes of Congress this is really just the
straw that broke the camel's back it
wasn't this specific incident the Hulk
had been trashing a bunch of cities Nick
Fury had been waging a secret war then
there was all the end a drama from the
x-men comics that have been going on so
the government was just like this is
enough we need to register all these
weapons of mass destruction they termed
super heroes and super villains as
living weapons of mass destruction
it's kind of like a gun registration act
like you have to register your weapon
only the person is the weapon but the
reason Captain America got so upset
about that is because he felt it was a
violation of civil liberties like you
had the right to protect your identity
the reason Iron Man was on the other
side of that
because he was just so choked up by all
these children dying all these innocent
people dying because of this
uncontrolled superhero event they being
the symptom of a much bigger problem so
iron man's like okay we need to fix this
problem or more innocent people are
gonna die so that's how they wound up on
different sides of that now Civil War
itself like the actual battles didn't
blow up right away there wasn't like an
immediate thing it was only after
Captain America refused to sign the
Registration Act and turned into
something of a criminal in the eyes of
the government so because shield is a
government organization Maria Hill had
to bring him in so he pulled one of
those elevator scenes from Winter
Soldier where like they all tried to
jump on him at the same time and he
escapes basically jumps out of a shield
Helicarrier in midair and then runs off
to form his resistance both sides dig
their heels in and then real villains
come out to use the chaos to their
advantage so I'll say spoiler warning
for the end of comic book Civil War I
don't necessarily think it's gonna be
the exact same in movie civil war so I
don't consider it a super spoiler for
the movie or anything like that so here
we go crossbones acting on the orders of
the Red Skull ends up assassinating
Captain America and they secretly make
it look like someone else said it it
becomes this big whodunit everyone
thinks that Captain America is dead he
really ends up coming back and this big
twist later but Ironman is left sitting
over caps body just feeling like an
[ __ ]
so after that our cuz when Mighty
Avengers happen Tony Stark got taken
over by Ultron they wanted people to
sympathize with Iron Man again because
it came out of Civil War seeming like
kind of a dick and of course the rest is
history
so already you see a couple problems
with comic books Civil War it's like
well they have a couple the same people
that they have in comic book Civil War
Marvel doesn't have the rights to any of
the x-men characters so there's a bunch
of people you couldn't include they've
already done Ultron so they can't do the
aftermath of Civil War in the same way
and Chris Evans and a bunch of the other
characters are gonna be reciting their
marvel contracts so already they're
gonna have to reconfigure things but you
can kind of see how in the movie Iron
Man and Captain America going at each
other will just create a lot of chaos
and then people like Baron Zemo
crossbones will use that to their
advantage now hopefully you've seen the
civil war trailer five billion times if
you haven't I'll put a link in the
description but the sokovia accords are
just a little bit different from the
superhero Registration Act in the comics
is essentially an accountability factor
for the Avengers
government wants to regulate the
Avengers because of what happened in
sokovia but that's just the straw that
broke the camel's back
the government's probably been waiting
to control the Avengers for a long time
you could go all the way back to the
Battle of New York in the wake of that
eve even daredevil on Netflix has
referenced the Battle of New York and
how people have had to rebuild so all
the TV shows all the movies link back to
that event is this big catastrophe that
was caused by the Avengers trying to
fight aliens so the government gets
really scared when stuff like sokovia
happens and the avengers just roll out
this massive private army funded by Tony
Stark they wanted they want to do
something about it so that's where the
sokovia accords are born the face of the
government is going to be general
Thunderbolt Ross now he is not a villain
but he is also a super big [ __ ]
so you can see that they don't want you
to take any clear side like he
definitely has a reason for wanting to
regulate the Avengers but he's a total
[ __ ] so you don't want to sympathize
with him too much Captain America in the
movie doesn't seem like he's quite as
worried about civil liberties being
violated with liquid the superhero
Registration Act as he might be with the
government trying to use the Avengers as
a tool his name is Captain America but
just like Superman wants to be a hero
for the entire world
Captain America also cares about all the
people of the world so it sounds like he
just doesn't want the Avengers to turn
into a private army that the government
can use like an attack dog when it sees
somebody that they don't like like oh
this other country is acting up they're
not doing something that is in the best
interests of America so Avengers go take
care of them so most of the fun of movie
civil war is trying to pick a site like
you know who do you believe in the most
because both people right like Captain
America and Iron Man both have really
good positions to take general
Thunderbolt Ross isn't necessarily in
the wrong but he also looks really
sinister then you know the real villains
like Baron Zemo and crossbones I'm
assuming that instead of Red Skull
controlling crossbones like in the
comics it's gonna be Baron Zemo working
with crossbones or Eddie you might be a
little confused there's just so much
stuff going on like how does the Winter
Soldier figure into all this what I
think is is that the Winter Soldier will
just be the straw that broke the camel's
back between Captain America and Iron
Man
when fists actually start to fly yeah
Captain America doesn't want to sign the
sokovia accords but that's no reason for
Iron Man to start punching him in the
face the emergence of Winter Soldier is
probably what throws gasoline on that
flame
we all know that everything is gonna go
to complete [ __ ]
but the Russos did say that spider-man
is gonna help balance the tone of the
film just like lighten it up just a
little bit so that you're not crying in
the entire time it's actually a pretty
fascinating story when you learn about
how Captain America 3 turned into
Captain America Civil War Robert Downey
jr. went to the studio to you know
talked with like all the big suits and
said hey you know here's an idea
for using me in that Captain America
film it's a little more complicated than
that but but you get the idea Robert
Downey jr. is like I don't really want
to do a solo film but I do want to
participate so here's a couple other
places that you can use me without me
having to completely hold up the entire
film by myself we all dream that we have
that kind of bargaining power I know
who's gonna talk a little bit about
Secret Wars but it doesn't seem quite as
relevant now I was basically just gonna
explain how they get rid of characters
without fridging them completely like
they would have done to Chris Evans had
he decided to leave Captain America as a
franchise Fantastic Four in the comics
is done like there are no Fantastic Four
comics that are being planned in the
near future and they kind of wrote that
into the end of Secret Wars that was
what the end of Secret Wars was meant to
do
be the last Fantastic Four story at
least for a while so Marvel hasn't given
up on the Fantastic Four it's just kind
of putting them on the shelf for a while
and that's what it's gonna do to any of
the actors in the Avengers franchise
that do not want to do any more movies
it really sounds more complicated than
it actually is Marvel just has a bunch
of different plans based on crazy
decisions that actors might make but
wait guys wait for my next video you can
click here for all my Captain America
Civil War videos and you can click here
for all my Batman V Superman videos they
posted a bunch of footage last night
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you